[Musica]
ben trovati oggi voglio parlarvi di
quanto poco conosciamo del nostro
universo
in particolare della materia oscura per
fare questo immaginiamo di avere degli
occhi particolari occhi che riescano ad
osservare particelle microscopiche
infinitamente microscopiche e iniziamo
un viaggio
innanzitutto guardiamo in alto quello
che vedremo e una pioggia di particelle
che ci investe ci investe per tutta la
vita
queste particelle le chiamiamo buoni i
buoni sono prodotti a 10 chilometri di
altezza nell'atmosfera da altre
particelle che vagano vagano nella
galassia anche dagli estremi della
galassia fino ad arrivare sulla terra
quanti buoni riceviamo costantemente dal
cielo bene
immaginiamo con i nostri occhi speciali
di guardare l'unghia del nostro pollice
in un minuto
vedremo due buoni attraversare l'unghia
nel minuto successivo altri due in media
ora chiediamoci i muoni sono le uniche
particelle abbondanti che ci investono
durante tutto il corso della nostra vita
no e quindi continuiamo il nostro
viaggio e andiamo verso il sole a 150
milioni di chilometri
qui vedremo che il sole emette una
grandissima quantità di energia e
tantissime particelle che questa volta
chiamiamo neutrini i neutrini sono
particelle che interagiscono pochissimo
con la materia e possono attraversare
distanze infinite pianeti stelle senza
mai interagire però abbiamo acquisito
una conoscenza e una tecnologia capace
di catturare le interazioni di neutrini
quanti neutrini riceviamo dal sole bene
sulla terra riceviamo 60 miliardi di
neutrini attraverso la nostra unità
quindi se riuscissimo a vedere l'unghia
vedremo in un secondo 60 miliardi di
neutrini costantemente ci attraversano
per tutta la vita
in che modo osservare una interazione di
neutrini dobbiamo continuare il nostro
viaggio e muoverci nel sottosuolo
quindi in un laboratorio in sotterraneo
come il laboratorio del gran sasso in
italia di questi laboratori ce n'è una
decina sparsi in tre continenti
nei laboratori in sotterraneo i muoni
che abbiamo conosciuto precedentemente
non possono arrivare poiché sono
assorbiti dalla roccia che sovrasta il
laboratorio in questi laboratori
possiamo aprire nuovi orizzonti per lo
studio di fenomeni molto rari quali le
interazioni dei neutrini solari o le
interazioni di materia oscura che cos'è
la materia oscura
facciamo un jump indietro nel tempo
negli anni trenta del secolo scorso
quando swi chi studia la dinamica delle
galassie in un ammasso di galassie noto
come chioma di berenice in questo
ammasso wiki dimostra che la massa
globale dell'ammasso è molto maggiore
della massa luminosa cioè della massa
delle galassie dei gas che ospitano la
galassia quanto è più luminosa lui
scopre ed è una scoperta straordinaria
che la massa globale dell'ammasso e
circa 400 volte maggiore della massa
luminosa dell'ammasso di galassie quindi
un universo è un ammasso di galassie
costituito prevalentemente da materia
non visibile che lui denomina materia
oscura
ora facciamo un altro jump e andiamo a
40 anni dopo negli anni settanta del
secolo scorso quando vera ruby in studia
il moto delle stelle moto di rotazione
intorno al centro delle galassie come
sapete una galassia intorno al centro è
dominata da stelle la densità di stelle
alta e man mano questa densità
diminuisce muovendosi in periferia fino
a quando la galassia diventa piano piano
più scura meno luminosa bene le stelle
che si muovono in quella regione hanno
un modo caratteristico simile al moto
dei pianeti del sistema solare
bene il moto dei pianeti del sistema
solare è caratterizzato dal fatto che la
massa del sistema solare è concentrata
nel sole quindi man mano che ci si
allontana dal sole la velocità di questi
pianeti diminuisce in un modo noto noto
sin dai tempi di newton quello che verrà
rog rubin scopre e straordinariamente e
che al contrario nelle stelle nelle
periferie delle galassie hanno una
velocità costante di circa 150
chilometri al secondo e dovrebbero
allontanarsi per sempre dalle galassie
non continuare a ruotare intorno al
centro perché di nuovo la materia oscura
può spiegare questa dinamica quindi
scopre vera rubin che almeno la materia
oscura ha un'abbondanza nelle galassie
dieci volte superiore a quella della
materia luminosa le stelle e il gas
sappiamo oggi studiare la materia oscura
bene per studiare la materia oscura di
nuovo il nostro
viaggio ci porta in sotterraneo tuttavia
prima di muoverci in sotterraneo
dobbiamo sottolineare che negli ultimi
decenni gli scienziati osservando
l'universo hanno scoperto che di questo
universo noi conosciamo solo il 5 per
cento
il 5 per cento è costituito da ciò di
cui siamo noi fatti i pianeti il sole il
90 per del 5 per cento da entità oscure
energia oscura e materia oscura oggi noi
qui parliamo di materia oscura andando
in un laboratorio in sotterraneo
gli scienziati hanno sviluppato
tecnologie in grado di catturare eventi
di materia oscura
in che modo immaginiamo di avere una
massa di argon ocse non liquido siamo
almeno 100 gradi sotto lo zero gradi
centigradi in questa massa una ipotetica
particella di materia oscura interagisce
con un nucleo di xenon ad esempio
produce un flash di luce questo flash di
luce fornisce un segnale primario
poi il grappolo di elettroni che viene
formato dalla interazione produce con un
ritardo un segnale secondario lo studio
del segnale primario e secondario
fornisce ai ricercatori le
caratteristiche della particella di
materia oscura
dunque alla fine di questo viaggio
abbiamo compreso quanto poco conosciamo
dell'universo e ci resta no due domande
che vorrei proporvi la prima domanda è è
difficile studiare la materia oscura
sì abbiamo visto che la prima evidenza
di materia oscura risale a 90 anni fa e
gli scienziati pensano che dovremmo
ancora lavorare per almeno 10 anni per
capirne la natura
seconda domanda è importante lo studio
della materia oscura
questo sì è un jump fondamentale perché
osservando l'universo così come lo
vediamo oggi la sua evoluzione nel tempo
e nella forma che osserviamo oggi questo
è dovuto alla materia oscura
noi siamo dovuti alla materia oscura le
galassie e gli ammassi di galassie di
cui abbiamo parlato sono così come li
osserviamo grazie alla materia oscura
pertanto per noi è un jump fondamentale
un paradigma fondamentale nella nostra
conoscenza svelare la natura della
materia oscura che potrebbe aprirci un
nuovo orizzonte
grazie